ah this does put a smile on my face
[Music]
all right in vengers infinity war is
just around the corner and this is a
prep video this is partly an exercise
for me partly to help folks out there
who don't want to marathon all of the
other Marvel movies that have been made
up to this point so this is me going
through the characters that are going to
be peering in this and basically bring
you up to speed on the last time we saw
them I'm not doing a complete history of
all these characters and other actions
in the MCU but I am gonna talk about
where we last left off with them so you
can use this to get you to get yourself
and just basically be a reminder like oh
yeah that's what that character was so
that you don't have to comb through all
the other movies up to this point so
let's get this rolling and we're gonna
start cuz I've got several sections
worth of this we're gonna start with the
characters who we know for certain are
going to be appearing in Avengers
infinity war so let's start with Captain
America Steve Rogers who actually I
should probably refer to as that because
he is no longer carrying the rank or
mantle of Captain America he left that
behind
along with his original vibranium shield
at the end of civil war he has broken
off from the Avengers he has not had
direct contact with any of them since
civil war that we are aware of and he
also knows about Wakanda because he left
Bucky there on in the extra-credit scene
at the end of civil war so cap has
basically gone underground since the
events of his own last film next up the
other side of the Civil War conflict
Tony Stark Iron Man so at the end of the
Civil War and the events of that he has
basically been left as the de facto
leader of the Avengers at least as best
as we understand it that's because there
hasn't been a proper Avengers film since
the events of that but he does seem to
be trying to get things back to
assemblance of whatever passes
with the Avengers we saw a little bit of
that in spider-man homecoming with him
kind of grooming Peter for membership as
an actual Avenger so he does he antonius
all US interest in the Avengers and what
the Avengers are meant to be next up
Thor last seen in Thor Ragnarok now
where we left off with him his homeworld
of Asgard has been destroyed he he and
most of the population of Asgard aldia's
Guardians including his adoptive brother
Loki were on a ship basically headed out
to we weren't entirely sure where but to
try and make a new home for themselves
also quick reminder for him he doesn't
have the hammer anymore that got the
story he's got lightning powers now that
he kind of always had him was really
just channeling through the hammer but
he is he cannot do them without the
hammer he's also missing an eye and he
is now officially the ruler and leader
of Asgard or at least its citizens since
Asgard the place is no longer around
since we touched on him let's also touch
on Loki real quick Loki I don't want to
say it looks like he turned a leaf
because it's Loki who knows but what we
can pretty much be certain of and at
this point I'll point out that I am
basing this strictly off of their
previous appearances I this is not a
dissection of what we've already seen in
the trailers so I don't look for me to
be including too much of that
information here but Loki pretty much
definitely picked up the tesseract from
the Asgard vault on his way out and Thor
does not know that now the tesseract
remember is one of the Infinity stones I
believe it is the space stone so this is
immediately gonna put them on Van houses
radar which is not good also lumped up
with that whole group we have Hulk now
Hulk when we last saw him here and in we
did last see him in Hulk form and when
last it was brought up banner said that
if it became hook again he may not be
able to turn back so he's now Hulk again
and having become Hoek he did so knowing
he may not ever be
able to regain control of his own body
again and this was of course following
his voluntary leaving of the planet
Earth because it just wasn't working for
him and he was a gladiator on the
planets a car for a while that all
happened during thor ragnarok and he's
now basically last we saw him was all
hooked up with or the other as Guardians
Black Widow was last seen in Captain
America Civil War kind of playing both
sides initially she sided with Tony
however when push came to shove and the
chips were down ultimately she sided
with cap and she has kind of gone silent
since then so far as we know most likely
she is underground and hiding just try
to escape the consequences of what she
did and having helped out cap at the
very end there
Hawkeye also not seen since the event of
Captain America Civil War he sided with
cap right off the bat he can pretty much
bet that he is also in some form of
hiding Scarlet Witch last seen in
Captain America Civil War she sided with
team cap now at the time we last saw her
she was beginning to build a
relationship with the vision so exactly
where that is now considering they were
on opposing sides of the conflict in
that we don't know it is unlikely that
she went into hiding at the end of civil
war she is probably still with the
Avengers she doesn't really have
anywhere else to go
and of course I already mentioned him
vision last seen in Captain America
Civil War and in that he sided with Tony
so he is undoubtedly still at the
Avengers complex and working with that
group at this point there is the Falcon
also Lessing in Captain America Civil
War not entirely clear what his standing
would be it's not quite as an obvious
thing that he would now be in hiding the
way spies like Hawkeye and Black Widow
would be so his exact status in the wake
of having been on I don't want to say
the losing side but the side that is not
in command of Avengers you know their
facility and their tactics in there and
their mission
and everything exactly where he is right
now it is hard to say more machine Rodie
so he is in physical therapy trying to
get the use of his legs back following
basically being the guy who took the
nastiest spill in the big airport fight
in Captain America Civil War I have
little doubt that Tony is probably
helping him with tech to get him on his
feet again we know it's possible there
the technology exists to get him going
again exactly where he'll be in terms of
recovery when the new film starts up
hard to say but he is he sided with Tony
he's still there Tony feels very
responsible for what happened to him and
they are they're still together they're
still buds alright let's get off this
planet let's talk about some of the
cosmic folks let's run down the
guardians of the allottee real quick we
got star-lord who had a couple little
twists happen in terms of what he
learned about himself he's basically
half celestial he's practically half God
what that will actually mean in
practical terms probably not a lot
because at by the end of guardians of
the galaxy volume 2 the source that he
was drawing power from was gone we've
got Rocket Raccoon also last evening
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 who seems
to be maybe possibly finally getting to
a place where he's gonna start being a
little bit more trusting a little bit
less of a jerk on to his teammates but
you know he's temperamental
we'll see we've got Gamora now Gamora
also last seen in guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 she is in the distinct
place of being one of the few characters
with direct links and connections to
Thanos
our big villain we'll get to him
eventually so Gamora was his adopted
daughter her along with one other
character who again we'll touch on a
little bit now she has very little
desire to get involved with Thanos she
would very much prefer to not ever see
him ever ever again someone who would
like to see him again though is Drax the
destroyer also last seen in guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 he had previously sworn
revenge against Ronan the accuser the
villain of the first scars of the galaxy
who was
killed at the end of that film following
that Drax then swore to take down Thanos
although judging by his actions and his
general demeanor in guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 he's not as committed and
isn't quite going at it with the same
level of angst and gusto that he did
when he went after Ronan so what I have
nobody out is still a goal for him it's
not quite the obsession that it was when
he was going after Roman great last
scene as well primarily seen as a baby
Groot in guardians of the galaxy vol 2
post-credit scene or mid-credits scene
in that we saw him basically as teenage
Groot so odds are he'll be somewhere
between that and full-grown by the time
we see him in Avengers 4 now in terms of
his abilities he can probably pretty
much do most of the stuff that he that
we saw adult Groot do actually even
little group could do a lot of that
stuff so he's probably not particularly
limited he's probably as strong and as
versatile and as deadly as we saw him in
the original guardians of the galaxy at
this point mantas new additions of the
guardians of the galaxy first and last
and only scene in gardens the galaxy vol
2 she is an empath and she that gives
her the ability to sort of hook into
people's feelings doesn't have a lot of
combat skill seems to be you know still
finding her place within the Guardians
group where she could possibly land in
terms of a conflict of this scope not a
clue but we'll see nebula the character
I personally am most interested in
seeing what's going on this is the other
adopted daughter of Thanos and unlike
Gamora who would just as soon walk away
from all that nebula oh so much rage so
much fury in this woman she wants to
take Fanus apart one molecule at a time
she is fueled by so much hate and so
much pain and she was last seen
basically going off to try and find him
to kill him she really really wants to
kill him we're gonna jump around
franchises a little bit more we have dr.
Steven strange last seen in Thor
Ragnarok where he assisted Thor in
locating owed
so at this point he seems to have
settled into his role he's not the
sorcerer supreme yet at least so far as
I could tell but he is settling into his
role and his use in this world is kind
of being a go-to guy where magic could
either help or has already evolved in
the situation that's going on he has
been in direct possession of one of the
Infinity stones that was the time gem
that was in the eye of agamotto whether
or not he will still be in personal
physical possession of that when this
film starts not entirely clear but he's
had it once before he knows where it is
he knows how to get it so one would
assume he's the link into that also from
that same franchise we have Wong who is
another sorcerer he's friends with dr.
Steve estranged last seen in Doctor
Strange he is a member of the sorcerer
order and he's a good guy not really too
much more to say some more supporting
characters Valkyrie newcomer since Thor
Ragnarok she was a fallen warrior from
Asgard from a group of warrior woman who
tried to take down the villain hello way
back when it did not go well she was the
only one who survived she became kind of
a bitter hard-drinking bounty hunter
type and she you know has not been able
to completely get rid of her sense of
duty or sense of right and wrong so she
was last seen with Thor and Loki and all
the Asgardians
how about we talk Scott Lang neikei
ant-man last seen in Captain America
Civil War he was he sided with cap he
was captured we do believe that he was
released whether or not he was granted
his tecnique technology the ant-man suit
back following his release
we actually don't really know that one
way or the other right now
buta Parker spider-man last seen in
spider-man homecoming where he turned
down Tony's iron spider armor and a spot
in the Avengers somewhat unknowingly he
thought that Tony was just giving him a
test sit he was supposed to turn it down
except it was a real
her and Peter just kind of turned it
down but that's where we last saw him he
seems to have a pretty good handle on
his powers at this point and he's you
know he's still in high school he's
still working working on balancing
everything out but he seems to be in a
decent place as far as Peter Parker
tends to be which you know he doesn't
hugely stay in a good place for long if
you know much about him everybody's
favorite royal to cha the black panther
last seen in of course black panther now
where things left off with him having
had to contend and a fight to keep his
throne he has now done something that
has never happened with the secretive
and very powerful and very
technologically advanced nation of
Wakanda which is he is bringing the
knowledge that they have to the world up
to this point what Conda has been
secretive cut off hiding itself from the
rest of the world so as not to be
exploited to be able to protect his
people as well as possible and T'Challa
has taken the step of bringing what they
have to offer to the global table so
that was where we last saw him literally
addressed in the United Nations saying
we are bringing to you our technology
and our abilities speaking of Wakanda
we've got a Kuei the lead general and
greatest warrior of the wakandan
security forces she will be around she
was last seen in Black Panther she she
is loyal to the king she is a heck of a
fighter she'll be around also Cherie
this is two challahs little sister
scientific genius head researcher and
developer of weapons and medical tech
and really pretty much everything that's
really cool in Wakanda and since we're
talking Bucky Barnes we got one more
resident to talk about who we know is
appearing and that is Bucky Barnes
the Winter Soldier last seen in the
post-credits sequence of the Black
Panther film where we saw him
sands any kind of artificial arm at all
actually this one isn't it
or is it this one whichever arm it is he
didn't have an artificial arm at all he
seemed really chill really Zen
seems to have bonded a little bit with
Cherie and they does appear to be
actually in a pretty good place which is
slightly surprising because prior to
this the last time we'd seen him was at
the very end of Captain America Civil
War being put on ice and basically being
like I need to we need to figure out how
to unprogrammed me because I'm a danger
to everybody so the presumption might be
that he is either now deprogrammed or in
this is somehow the process of
deprogramming him also confirmed to be
appearing let me burn through some of
these this god there's a lot of
characters we've got Heimdall the
Asgardian he is with all the other as
Guardians with Thor and Loki and
Valkyrie on that ship we've got dr. Erik
Selvig who was who is an earthling and a
professor and a friend of Thor we
haven't seen him since Avengers age of
Ultron where he was assisting Thor in
getting a vision which was a scene that
largely was just cut from the film for
time we have hope Van Dyne the wasp last
seen in the original ant-man getting her
suit whether or not we will see her in
the suit in infinity war hard to say
kind of unlikely while I'm not gonna
bring up the trailer footage we've seen
for infinity war it does seem like the
trailer footage we've seen for ant-man
and the wasp that she's only just
starting to go out and make use of the
suit so she is supposed to appear
whether or not she will appear as the
wasp
that is a that is not a guarantee Baku
known in the comic books as the man 8
the leader of a specific tribe of
Wakanda initially antagonistic to
T'Challa later an ally of his he is
confirmed to be reappearing and it's not
entirely clear how smooth the
relationship between him and T'Challa
will be at this point but they seem to
end things on pretty decent terms when
last we saw them there is the collector
played by
Benicio del Toro we have not seen him
since guardians of the galaxy one after
his collection was smashed up rather
severely now we last saw him in
possession
of the ether which is one of the
Infinity stones it has not been it has
not been seen being held by anybody else
so even though the collectors the whole
thing got smashed up presumably he is
still in possession of that particular
one of the Infinity stones let's talk
the baddies we know are gonna be in here
the big one Thanos last time we saw him
actually appear it was the first
guardians the galaxy and he was
employing Ronan to attempt to get him to
acquire one of the Infinity stones it
was the power stone in that particular
case we now know of course that he is
going about trying to get all these
himself he's not employing you know
folks like groaning to do it for him
anymore that was last time we saw him
directly
he's been referenced since then there
were a number of references to him in
guards the galaxy vol 2 but more about
his past rather than his current
movement so presumably he's just kind of
been working on figuring out where the
stones are between the last time we saw
him in guardians the galaxy vol 1 and
now now Thanos has four minions he's
gonna be bringing with him all these are
characters who have not been seen before
so I really don't have anything to tell
you about them I'll just run down their
names real quick we have Corvus glaive
Proxima midnight M edema and black dwarf
that's all the characters who have been
confirmed somewhere or other to be
appearing in Avengers if in any war
however we're not done because they shot
infinity war and Avengers for pretty
much back to back so we have a list of
characters who have been confirmed to
appear in Avengers 4 so let's go through
those because some of them were ones I
didn't already cover first up Captain
Marvel she has yet to debut she will be
debuting in her own film being played by
brie Larson that comes out between
infinity war and Avengers 4 we do know
that that film is a period piece set in
the 90s but exactly where she's gonna
end up at the end of that I can't
predict we're gonna be getting back
Pepper Potts and happy Hogan both last
seen in the tail end of spider-man
homecoming Pepper Potts being Tony
Stark's love interest they did reconcile
they are back together again presumably
tony has now proposed happy hogan being
tony's former bodyguard now chauffeur
just kind of good friend employee guy
and he actually kind of kept an eye on
peter parker for a while he probably is
not being called on to do that as much
these days but he could be we don't know
we've got Nick Fury and Maria Hill both
last seen in Avengers age of Ultron
where they came up holy up the
Helicarrier to help evacuate sokovia
neither of them we have seen since then
presumably Nick Fury still needs to kind
of keep below the radar keeping out of
the watch of various organizations both
probably within the US government and
other forces as well who just want him
dead as for Maria hill not really sure
what she's been up to
she may or may not have appeared on
agents of shield since then I'm sorry I
don't know I'm not gonna look that up
last time saw in a movie was age of
Ultron just kind of helping everybody
out here's a weird one for you Harley
keener is returning name you probably
don't recognize this was the kid in Iron
Man 3 who helped out Tony when he kind
of crashed and needed to work on getting
his suit up and running again that
characters coming back I'm not sure what
else there is to say last we saw him he
was just a small kid who was helping out
Tony as best as a small kid could yeah
so those are all the confirmed
characters or at least the ones that I
could find being confirmed I'm sure some
people will tell me that some of the
ones I'm about to talk about were also
confirmed or maybe some of the ones that
I said were confirmed are actually
rumored let me just get through the rest
of these now sign for the characters who
it is possible or there has been rumor
that they were they will appear nothing
is confirmed first up Hank Pym the
original ant-man the man who made Scott
Lang suit no confirmation that he will
appear it is possible if both Scott Lang
and hope Van Dyne are appearing Hank Pym
would make sense because he's certainly
very much tied to them especially if
hope is going out in the wasp suit you
know for the first time or early into
her career for that but not confirmed
that he will be appearing we have not
seen him since the events of ant-man
Queen R Amanda this is two challahs
mother last seen in black panther alive
and well she holds no official power as
her son is now king but she is well
respected and beloved and may or may not
be appearing in these films refugees
from the planets a car korg and meek
these are two gladiators that Thor met
in the course of Thor Ragnarok they were
last seen traveling with with the
Asgardians one would presume that they
would show up then if this film does
tackle what happens to the Asgardians
and one would think that it would
because we got a cover a Thor but we
don't know for certain that they will
appear will see Nova prime played by
Glenn Close last seen in guardians of
the galaxy vol 1 now we don't have a
confirmation that she's gonna come back
it would make a lot of sense though
because she was the last known person to
be in possession of the power gem as the
Nova Corps took possession of that to
guard it directly linked to that would
be Roman day which is a member of the
Nova Corps played by john c reilly also
last seen in guardians of the galaxy
we have Sharon Carter agent of shield
last seen the Civil War
assisting Captain America we do not know
if she had to answer consequences for
that or what they might have been and it
is possible that she may not be
appearing in this film at all this is a
one that I've seen this is more of a
theory than a rumor but I'm just gonna
touch on it real quick I've seen some
people speculate that hella played by
Kate Blanchet the villain of Thor Eggen
arc would be appearing in one or both of
the Avengers films that are coming up I
think the theory behind this is is
because she is the goddess of death and
Thanos is traditionally in love with
death that she's basically sort of
subbing in because in the comics danos
is actually in love with the physical
embodiment of death and that's not what
hella is she's just a goddess of death
but the theory seems to be that hella is
substituting in for that
physical embodiment of death that Thanos
is more traditionally in love with in
the comic books and the argument seems
to largely be based around the fact that
we saw her and Thor Ragnar be on Asgard
when Ragnarok happened but we didn't see
her die specifically so it's possible
she could come back I don't think this
one's true but I'll throw it out there
it's possible
another odd one that might have
accidentally been slipped by one of the
actors the ancient one might appear in
some capacity is this was character
played by Tilda Swinton Mark Ruffalo had
mentioned having worked with her
recently in an interview and that may
have been an accidental slip that she is
making some kind of appearance in these
films or maybe he was talking about
something else completely I don't know
finally Lady SIF the one sort of big
supporter of Thor on Asgard
aside from Heimdall who did not die she
in fact did not appear at all in Thor
Ragnarok so whether or not they it is
possible for the character to be brought
back whether or not Marvel is just gonna
let the character quietly drop off and
not be dealt with or talked about again
like like what happened with Jane Foster
or Betty Ross and you know other side
characters that over time have just kind
of stopped appearing and falling away
who knows but it is possible for her to
come back we last saw her Wow in the
films in Thor the dark world she made an
appearance on on agents of shield I
think in the second season but we
haven't seen her in a while and now for
a few characters who are out there are
part of the MCU but we really don't know
what's going on with them and I would
classify these as unlikely to appear
these would include characters like Jane
Foster who has now broken up with Thor
and effectively has no reason to appear
she didn't appear in Thor Ragnarok she
basically just got a mention that
they're not together anymore that's it
I expect Natalie Portman's just done
with this part Peggy Carter she passed
away in Captain America Civil War so
probably not getting that back crag
Lanai
the Ravagers last seen with the
guardians of the galaxy but I not shoot
I'm not sure that we should expect to
see him with that group in this film I
would be very surprised I mentioned her
earlier Betty Ross love interest for the
Incredible Hulk last seen in the
Incredible Hulk the one with Ed Norton
the one that they kind of pretend
doesn't exist anymore for for the most
part I don't expect her to show up again
because they seem to have completely
swapped in Black Widow as the potential
love interest for Bruce Banner also
related to that general Thunderbolt Ross
last seen in Captain America Civil War
character that they surprisingly did
bring back from The Incredible Hulk
movie I would not be expecting to see
him he was last seen pushing for the
sokovia accords but when things came
down to getting dirty he wasn't involved
in any of the fallout from that there's
also the abomination which it was
confirmed in the course of agents of
shield is still locked up and is being
kept under wraps unlikely that we'll see
him ditto Baron Zemo last seen in
Captain America Civil War also now
locked up there will be no reason for
him to be let out or if he did break out
for him to be participating in this
particular thing the man's got no powers
Baron Mordo villain to Doctor Strange he
is presumably out starting to hunt down
sorcerers he's on his own agenda
completely separate from any of this
don't expect to see him agent Everett
Ross played by Martin Freeman last seen
in black panther having gotten rather
miraculously healed up following taking
a bullet and i would be surprised if we
saw him since most of the sizes at this
point seem to be with black panther but
unless he just coincidentally happens to
be in Wakanda when stuff starts to go
down there wouldn't be a reason for him
to be appearing and finally sadly I
don't think we're gonna get an
appearance of Howard the Duck I know I
know
it's such a disappointment it's such a
waste but I don't think it's happening
guys last time we saw him was guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 propositioning a
robot hooker Oh
and we've got one more scant little
outlier that is a confirmed actor
without a confirmed part we don't Peter
Dinklage's in the movie we don't know
who he's playing and I'm not even gonna
bother guessing there are so many
characters that they could have him come
in and appear as and have him be or he
could just be somebody really minor they
have brought him really bad acting big
actors to play relatively minor parts so
that does evoke that's your prep video
for all piece frigging characters story
is super straight simple vanos wants the
Infinity stones if he gets all them he
can assemble the Infinity Gauntlet which
basically allows him to do anything and
his main goal is in his words to balance
the universe which seems to involve
killing about half the population of it
so there's your basic premise in terms
of what the threat is those are all your
characters that you can expect to see or
not see or maybe see who knows you're
now all set right crystal clear clear as
mud have fun with the movie so there's
all that stuff to do you know like
subscribe to or main patreon if you like
what I do
links for all that stuff is down in the
description hope you found this helpful
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]